Sony Pictures is stuck twiddling its
thumbs during the strike so it's looking
back at all the stuff it owns and
thinking what next could we reboot
and they've got a plan
and it's a helicopter one
hey welcome to soundtrack your Sci-Fi TV
and movie channel
[Music]
1983 Roy Scheider off the back of his
jaw success made a little movie called
Blue Thunder it was illegal to arm
police helicopters well that would
depend on the circumstances wouldn't it
Columbia Pictures presents Blue Thunder
I watched this recently it's actually
better than I remember it's more of a
political Intrigue movie than really
like helicopters flying around even
though there's been a long bit at the
end with helicopter slime out
it's actually quite a good film
made by Columbia Pictures back in the
day yes subsidiary of Sony Pictures it
was a reasonable success at the time and
actually did spawn its own TV series
that only lasted 11 episodes
[Music]
how about that
in addition to Firepower and accuracy
Blue Thunder has the most up-to-date
surveillance system there is short of
Science Fiction
infra thermograph pilot night vision
sensor system
laser spot tracker
back in 2015 eight years ago Marvel
writer and and producer Craig Kyle was
approached by Sony and he was asked to
develop a new screenplay or actually
work on an existing screenplay and
develop the new movie he actually did do
some work and other people were brought
on Michael DeLuca was the head of
Columbia pictures at the time even
though he then moved on to MGM and now
works for Warner Brothers that guy needs
to stay in a job for a few more years
and actually the 50 Shades of grave
producer Dana brunetti was set to also
produce that is a different kind of
movie but hey that's what the plan was
at the time now obviously it didn't
happen but actually this is a project
that still sits on Craig Kyle's IMDb as
in development eight years later
so why am I talking about this now well
as I say Sony has sat there twiddling
their thumbs with a strike outside cover
studios the picketers are walking up and
down constantly and the executives are
apparently bored so they're looking at
all of the projects that they have in
development trying to decide which ones
they want to push forwards with once the
strikes end and they have brushed the
dust off Blue Thunder according to one
of the sources that I speak to they are
genuinely very serious about this and
conversations with Craig Kyle have
already happened now I should say that
at the moment nobody is attached to this
but Sony are very interested in moving
forward with Craig Kyle's ideas
but with some quite big changes so
initially Craig Kyle was hoping for this
to be a drone movie because this is 2015
don't forget everything was drones now
with all the bumps that came out of time
this was being called the first big sort
of like major drone movie but I would
actually argue that 10 years previously
the stealth film had come out with Jamie
Foxx Joss Lucas and Jessica Biel and
that was basically a man vs drone movie
and that didn't do very well and that
was big budget it was actually I
actually quite enjoyed that film but
anyway it didn't do very well at the box
office so all that stuff at the time was
nonsense
Sony though have apparently seen the
light and according to the source that I
speak to have sort of been knocking this
idea around the office for a week or two
and asking for several different
Executives and creative people sort of
throw in their two pence the idea now
being really that it will not be a
solely drone movie they're saying look
there's no tension there's no real
danger if it's just a drone flying
around even though obviously in the Blue
Thunder movie the chances are the Drone
would have gone crazy and tried to kill
everyone probably but
you know what I mean there's no sort of
risk there so they want to scrap that
idea they also have had enough sense to
realize that blue thunder is a
helicopter with people on board are cool
and drones with nobody on board aren't
so the Blue Thunder will be a helicopter
once again a military helicopter over La
I've heard that the reboot will follow
roughly the original storyline IE La
lots of crime there's an experiment or a
study to see if a military helicopter
flying over a cities like La would be a
useful thing to have
support kind of like the idea of it no
guns no kicking in doors you know
quiet
oh yeah for Frank Murphy policing the
air has its helps
something that is actually technically
illegal under American law but the movie
will also have a political Intrigue
element again it wants to follow roughly
the same storyline as the original but
I've seen them more updated up-to-date
version remembering the original was
actually 40 years ago now God I'm old so
I actually think this is a really really
interesting idea now I actually did tell
you guys a little while ago that there
were plans for an air wolf reboot but
those plans seem to have paused if we're
not getting a very cool helicopter
Airwolf reboot though I'd be okay with a
very cool helicopter Blue Thunder reboot
this is actually a film I really enjoyed
and I don't know why but helicopters are
cool
so if they do a political thriller with
a cool helicopter flying around L.A
shooting the crap out of everything
I think it could be good fun
but it's not going to be a cinematic
movie Sony pictures are looking at this
as a streaming movie and the reason why
I found out about this is because the
source I spoke to is aware that they are
pitching the idea to a couple of the
bigger streaming services Netflix and
Apple tv plus being the primary focus of
that attention at the moment for me
though I actually think Netflix would be
the perfect place for a show like this
to drop and if it was going to be
produced by Sony it could be done with
very little risk to Netflix so I
actually think this is a pretty good
idea but what do you think would you
want to see a blue thunder streaming
Show on Netflix or anywhere else or is
this a show that you know doesn't really
have any relevance to today
or actually is it a basic storyline that
is relevant in most decades I'd love to
know exactly what you think get into the
comments
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you go to patreon.com forward slash
Sidetrack where you get to see most of
our new videos first and for a small
contribution each month that really
supports the channel and you even get a
free gift after three months you get to
see them without the adverts you can
also go to sidetrack.co.uk our dedicated
website where stories from most of our
videos appear with a little bit more
meat on the bones for you to digest
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
foreign
[Music]